und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek guten Abend
kiffen für alle die Legalisierung von
Cannabis das war eins der versprechen
die die selbst ernannte
fortschrittskoalition also die jetzige
Bundesregierung
2021 gegeben hat freier Rausch für freie
Bürger ein Anliegen besonders von FDP
und Grünen der Gesetzesentwurf den die
Regierung heute zur weiteren Beratung an
den Bundestag schickte kommt ein
bisschen bescheidener daher 25 Gramm
Cannabis für den Eigenbedarf sollen
danach künftig erlaubt sein genauso wie
der private Anbau von drei weiblichen
Pflanzen oder die organisierte Zucht in
einem Cannabis social club was cooler
klingt als Verein die Umsetzung bleibt
kompliziert und ist höchst umstritten
Dominik Müller Russell berichtet
Vereinssitzung des Cannabis-Clubs Kleve
am Niederrhein auf der Tagesordnung
natürlich ganz oben die Legalisierung
und was Sie jetzt tun müssen um loslegen
zu dürfen einen Jugendschutzbeauftragten
haben sie schon erahnt auch ein
Gewächshaus haben sie entworfen als
knifflig erweist sich noch die
Standortsuche für ihren Verein 200 m von
jeder Schule jedem Spielplatz entfernt
Lehrer und Unternehmer sind in ihrem
Reihen auch ein Polizist möchte Mitglied
werden das Gesetz für Sie die große
Chance endlich aus der Illegalität aus
der Schmuddelecke herauszukommen
wenn die Vereine das schaffen durch den
verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit dem
Gesetz zu zeigen das Cannabis wirklich
aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft kommt und
nicht aus der Randgruppe das wäre was da
würde ich persönlich sagen das wäre ein
Erfolg und das ist auch was worauf ich
mich freue weil ich glaube ich glaube
vielen Leuten ist nicht bewusst wie viel
Cannabis tatsächlich jetzt schon
konsumiert wird in Deutschland ein Ende
des schwarzmarkts stattdessen Milliarden
Geschäfte wittert die Industrie Cannabis
soll künftig auch einfacher von Ärzten
verschrieben werden können und
langfristig womöglich in Fachgeschäften
zu kaufen sein erwartet etwa der
Großhändler keiner medical aus Köln sie
stocken schon mal ihre Vorräte auf für
den Grünen goldrausch
es gibt keine vergleichbaren Märkte die
eine ähnliche ähnliche Wachstumsraten in
den kommenden Jahren haben man darf eben
nicht vergessen dass es equivalent zu
dem Ende der alkoholprovision es geht
also ein kompletten neues neue Phase in
diesem noch so jungen Markt auf und die
Wachstumsraten sind einfach phänomenal
die Teil Legalisierung soll nicht zu
mehr Konsum führen vor allem nicht bei
Kindern und Jugendlichen im Gegenteil
einer Aufklärungskampagne startet der
Bundesgesundheitsminister heute parallel
und verteidigt den Entwurf das gesamte
Thema wird enttaboisiert und die
Tatsache dass jetzt z.B über diese
Schäden viel gesprochen wird wirkt ja
schon Debatte findet schon statt daher
finde ich auch die Diskussion um das
Gesetz die ja Kontroverse ist nicht
schwierig sondern hilfreich aus
entgiftungsstationen aus Psychiatrien
und von Kinder und jugendmedizinern
kommt Kritik und auch von Cannabis
Süchtigen mit 12 Jahren fing ihr an zu
kiffen zuletzt waren es 10 bis 20 joints
am Tag
anfänglich war es dann dass ich alle
paar Wochen Wochenende mal ein paar
Joints geraucht hatte oder man paar
Wasserpfeifen durchgezogen hatte so und
dann wurden die Abstände immer kürzer
und mit der Zeit merkt man dann man
braucht halt eben einen Tag zu starten
ja es beherrscht an einem total es
werden mehr Menschen rauchen auch
Jugendliche davon gehen Sie hier aus und
deshalb werden auch mehr Menschen
Probleme bekommen gerade die jungen
deren Entwicklung noch nicht
abgeschlossen sein
häufig leiden Menschen die regelmäßig
Cannabis nehmen auch darunter dass sie
sich in ihrer Entwicklung also wenn man
jetzt von einem Staat im Jugendalter
ausgeht nicht richtig in die
Erwachsenenrolle hineinfinden was zum
Beispiel Beruf angeht in Team
Partnerschaft etc
verantwortungsvoll wollen sie
konsumieren und zeigen dass das eben
auch geht im cannabis-club in Kleve sind
sie froh sich künftig auf dem Boden des
Gesetzes zu bewegen und nicht mehr
verstecken zu müssen
darüber wollen wir reden mit
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach guten Tag nach Berlin guten
Tag feierlinek Cannabiskonsum ist sehr
gefährlich haben sie heute gesagt warum
wollen Sie Cannabis trotzdem teilweise
legalisieren müssen leider einräumen
dass die derzeitige Cannabis
Drogenpolitik gescheitert ist wir haben
steigenden Konsum auch bei jungen
Menschen bei Kindern und Jugendlichen
wir haben einen großen Schwarzmarkt der
weiter weg wir haben unreine Stoffe
Verunreinigungen toxische Konzentration
und wir haben eine große Kriminalität
mittlerweile ist es so dass die Hälfte
der Drogenkriminalität auf Cannabis
fällt somit so konnte es nicht
weitergehen wir müssen jetzt schauen
dass wir den Konsum für diejenigen die
konsumieren wollen Erwachsene dass sie
den sicherer machen ohne dass er
ausgedehnt wird und wir brauchen einen
besseren Schutz von Jugendlichen Kindern
und Jugendlichen und wir müssen warnen
vor dem Konsum der nicht wirklich
ungefährlich ist es gibt trotzdem
weibliche Zweifel dass der Schwarzmarkt
so zurückzudrängen ist weil man Cannabis
in kleinen Mengen zwar künftig besitzen
darf aber noch nicht legal kaufen kann
dafür muss man einem Verein beitreten
warum sollen Menschen das machen was
soll sie hindern weiterhin zum
Drogendealer zu gehen zunächst die Ware
beim Drogendealer ist ja oft
verunreinigt hat toxische Dosierungen
das macht niemand gerne wenn er eine
Alternative hatte wir wissen aus
internationalen Erfahrungen wenn es ein
legales Angebot gibt mit
Qualitätsstandards ohne beeinmengungen
dann ist das den Menschen natürlich
gerade den Gelegenheitskonsumenten
lieber und die also Mitgliedschaft in so
einem Verein der ist total
unbürokratisch wenn man sich dort aus
was ist 18 Jahre alt kann man dort
gelegentlich Cannabis kaufen für die
Vereinsmitgliedschaft das wird zum
Selbstkosten deckungspreis wie in einer
Genossenschaft angeboten das ist schon
eine starke Konkurrenz zum Schwarzmarkt
den werden wir damit zurück drängen
können ob der größte Teil
Cannabiskonsums wird über diese
Genossenschaften über diese Vereinen
Zukunft angeboten werden das sehen aber
die Befürworter der Legalisierung zum
Teil doch ganz anders die sagen diese
Cannabis social Clubs sind Bollwerke der
Bürokratie es gibt festgelegte Mengen
wie viel angebaut und abgegeben werden
darf man darf nicht dort konsumieren und
auch nicht im Umfeld von 200 Metern
sagen wir einer Kita oder einer
Fußgängerzone und es ist ungeklärt wer
das eigentlich alles kontrollieren soll
schon jetzt klagen Justiz und Politik
das ist vermutlich für Sie mehr Arbeit
gibt als weniger wissen sie ist oft ein
Zeichen eines guten Gesetzes dass es von
zwei Seiten angegriffen wird wir haben
hier auf der einen Seite diejenigen die
eine komplette Liberalisierung haben
wollen die dann hingehen wollen und
sagen das muss frei verkauflich sein
oder ohne Obergrenzen das ist uns
einfach zu gefährlich wir wollen den
Kinder und Jugendschutz in den
Vordergrund stellen und ein bisschen
Bürokratie ist ja notwendig um
tatsächlich sicherzustellen dass das
ganze nicht ausufert das nicht mehr
konsumiert wird auf der anderen Seite
ist aber nach wie vor unbürokratisch
denn diese Vereinsmitgliedschaft das ist
ja kein großer Deal wenn man so will da
wird man Mitglied man sagt den
Personalausweis es gibt keine besonderen
Bedingungen die erfüllt werden müssen
diese Vereine werden sich schnell
ausbilden das sehen wir jetzt schon das
Interesse ist groß ich glaube das ist
der Mittelweg wenig Bürokratie aber die
nur zum Gesundheitsschutz aber leicht
verfügbar Qualität die nicht also mit
dem Schwarzmarkt vergleichbar ist weil
wir haben hier eine Qualität ohne
beinengungen und eine Obergrenze 50
Gramm pro Monat muss man haben sonst
würden wir den Schwarzmarkt noch
beliefern zum Schluss trotzdem sie haben
Recht kritik kommt von allen Seiten z.B
auch von der Gewerkschaft der Polizei
die fragen sich wie das eigentlich
kontrolliert werden soll wird die
Polizei demnächst mit Zollstock
nachmessen ob die 200 Meter eingehalten
sind und mit Briefwaage dass die Menge
Cannabis nachwiegen
jetzt wird ja auch gewogen also derzeit
werden ja auch Delikte unter sechs Gramm
beispielsweise oder unter 10 Gramm die
werden nicht weiter verfolgt das heißt
das gewogen wird ist nichts
Außergewöhnliches und ich glaube dass
hier auch also sich sehr schnell eine
Praxis einbürgern wird dass man sehen
kann ist das hier an Verstoß oder nicht
darüber hinaus diese 200 Meter das ist
etwas was wir benötigen es kann nicht
sein dass im Umfeld von Kitas Schulen
und auch von
jugendstätten oder gar diesen
abbauvereinen geraucht werden kann oder
konsumiert werden kann wenn wir den
Kinder und Jugendschutz ernst nehmen
dann geht es nicht ganz ohne Bürokratie
aber sein Minimum am bürgerkratie sagt
der Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach zu einem Gesetzesentwurf mit
Risiken und Nebenwirkungen vielen Dank
für das Gespräch nach Berlin ich danke
Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir aus Termin
Gründen am Nachmittag aufgezeichnet und
wenn Sie wissen wollen welche Wirkstoffe
genau in den Cannabis Pflanzen stecken
und wie Sie auf unseren Körper wirken
können Sie das auf ZDF heute erfahren in
3D und interaktiv
der cannabis-gesetz Entwurf hat es also
noch durch Kabinett geschafft das heute
zum ersten Mal nach den Ferien mit
frischem Elan und guten Vorsätzen
zusammenkommen wollte vor genau drei
Tagen hatte der Kanzler noch im ZDF
gesagt er habe den Eindruck dass viele
in seiner Regierung sich über den Sommer
vorgenommen hätten den Ton in der
Koalition zu Ändern dieser Neustart ist
gründlich schief gegangen die grüne
Familienministerin verweigerte nämlich
heute im Kabinett ihre Zustimmung zu
einem Steuersenkungsgesetz von FDP
Finanzminister Lindner Lisa Paus fordert
mehr Geld fürs grüne Kernprojekt der
Kindergrundsicherung und schon greifen
sich gelbe und grüne wieder an alle
guten Vorsätze vergessen Diana
Zimmermann berichtet aus Berlin
Sommer Zeit runterzukommen um danach
alles mit frischem Schwung angehen zu
können so war es auch für das Kabinett
geplant dass ich heute seit der
Sommerpause zum ersten Mal wieder
zusammen fand 9 Gesetze auf der
Tagesordnung fast konnte man an einen
echten Neustart Glauben stattdessen ein
verkrampft lächelnder Finanzminister in
letzter Sekunde hatte Familienministerin
Paul sein Wachstumschancen gesetzt das
Unternehmen um 6 Milliarden Euro
entlasten soll blockiert ihr Ansatz wäre
Geld für Steuererleichterungen habe muss
er auch welches haben für die Kinder
Grundsicherung ihr Herzensprojekt dem
Lindner bislang die geforderten
Milliarden verweigert die FDP spricht
von Geiselhaft
ich erwarte da wirklich Bewegung bei
Frau Paust denn es kann ja nicht angehen
dass man sagt man will keine Stärkung
der Wirtschaft in Deutschland wenn man
sich um soziale Projekte kümmern will
das Gegenteil ist ja richtig wir
brauchen eine starke Wirtschaft um den
Sozialstaat zu finanzieren diesen
Zusammenhang muss frau Paus auch als
Familienministerin verstehen
Unterstützung bekommt Lisa Haus von
Umweltministerin Lemke vom Paritätischen
Wohlfahrtsverband und aus ihrer Fraktion
jetzt sofort Erpressung vorzuwerfen
finde ich falsch ich finde es richtiger
zu sagen dass wir große gesellschaftlich
wichtige Themen sowohl Wirtschaft als
auch andere Aspekte wie Kinder haben und
wie aber auch demokratischen
Zusammenhalt und andere Aspekte gut
Gewichten und abwägen müssen weder
Lindner noch Pause wollen uns heute ein
Interview geben vor den Toren des
Kanzleramts der Seufzer einer Kollegin
ich glaube dass es für alle Beteiligten
gut ist wenn wir Abläufe haben die etwas
stabiler sind und vorausschaubarer die
ursprünglich geplante Pressekonferenz
des Finanzministers wird abgesagt etwas
später findet die regierungs-pk statt wo
die Sprecherin alle neuen auf den Weg
gebrachten Gesetze vorträgt den Schaden
für das Image der Regierung aber nicht
erkennen will es geht hier um eine
Verschiebung um
wenige Tage oder oder Wochen und nicht
um ein Scheitern nichts wird hier
scheitern sondern diese Gesetze werden
kommen das ist wirklich die gemeinsame
Überzeugung der Bundesregierung
katastrophal nennt die Opposition diesen
Ansatz wir sind die einzigen das einzige
Land weit und breit das im Moment kein
Wirtschaftswachstum mehr hat wir müssen
jetzt dringend aufholen und die
investitionssituation für Unternehmen
verbessern wir dürfen da keine Woche
mehr tatenlos verstreichen lassen und
deswegen ist das Scheitern dieses
Gesetzes jetzt so fatal Ende
august auf Schloss Meseberg soll auch
Vorschlag des Kanzlers und des
Vizekanzlers das wachstumschancengesetz
bei einer Kabinettsklausur beschlossen
werden auch die Kindergrundsicherung
sondern entschieden sein
da müssen wir noch mal in Berlin
Nachfragen bei unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondentin shakunta la
benaji guten Abend der ampelfrieden hat
ja nicht lange gehalten sind Grüne und
FDP mittlerweile so verfeindet dass
ihnen die Außenwirkung dieses Streits
auf uns Bürger völlig egal ist es kann
Ihnen eigentlich nicht völlig egal sein
wie sie nach außen ankommt denn sie
sitzen gemeinsam in einer Regierung die
aktuell bei dem Bürgerinnen und Bürger
nicht in besonders hohem Ansehen steht
und zum Teil wirklich sehr schlechte
Noten bekommt im Politbarometer extra
sagen 73% Olaf Scholz setze sich bei
wichtigen politischen Fragen eher nicht
durch 74% bewerten das Verhältnis
zwischen den ampelpartnern als schlecht
und die Zufriedenheit mit der Ampel die
ist auch auf einem Tiefstwert also das
muss der Bundesregierung Sorgen bereiten
vor allem in Zeiten in den andere
Umfragen zeigen dass das Vertrauen in
den Staat singt und tatsächlich
beschwört die Ampel ja auch immer wieder
die gute Zusammenarbeit aber sie schafft
es eben nicht Streit hinter den Kulissen
bei deswegen so wie sie sich vorgenommen
hat sondern es gerät dann eben doch
immer wieder in die Öffentlichkeit und
der Kanzler greift nicht durch das zahlt
eher auf die schlechten Ansichten der
Bevölkerung einen in den Umfragen als
das Gegenteil zu bewirken und dann
entzündet sich dieser Streit ja
ausgerechnet auch noch an dem Gesetz
dass die Wirtschaft die echt schnell
entlasten sollte was ist denn noch übrig
vom gepriesenen deutschlandtempo dass
der Kanzler beschwört ja fairerweise
muss man sagen dass die Bundesregierung
heute einiges auf den Weg gebracht hat
was sie bis zum Ende des Jahres noch
durchsetzen möchte und auch das
wachstumschancengesetz das sogenannte
wird jetzt nicht an einer Verschiebung
von zwei Wochen scheitern sofern sich
die Ampel denn dann geeinigt hat denn
der Bundestag der Tag zum ersten Mal
nach der Sommerpause wieder am 4
September da geht die Sitzungswoche los
und bis dahin will man sich eben
geeinigt haben aber auch hier kommt es
eben auch auf die Außenwirkung an und da
bleibt eben der Eindruck stehen das
nicht immer das Tempo die oberste
Priorität hat wenn es um die Frage geht
Tempo oder Grundsatzfragen wird oft
gestritten und heute hat sich die Ampel
wieder einmal nicht fürs Tempo
entschieden danke nach Berlin
und es gab noch eine Überraschung in der
heutigen Kabinettssitzung und damit
beginnen die Nachrichten mit dir Gundula
das Kabinett hat auch das
haushaltsfinanzierungsgesetz gebilligt
das sieht verschiedene Einsparungen vor
um die Schuldenbremse im kommenden Jahr
einzuhalten überraschend ist das
kurzfristig aus dem Entwurf die
nato-quote für Verteidigungsausgaben
gestrichen wurde somit will sich die
Bundesregierung anders als kürzlich noch
von Kanzler Scholz zugesichert also auch
weiterhin nicht gesetzlich verpflichten
jährlich mindestens zwei Prozent der
Wirtschaftsleistung für Verteidigung
auszugeben
beschlossen hat das Bundeskabinett das
solarpaket um mehr Tempo beim
solarausbau zu erreichen hauptansatz der
Abbau der überborgenden Bürokratie für
Privatleute und gewerbliche Betreiber
Ziel ist bis 2030 den Anteil der
erneuerbaren Energien am brutto
Stromverbrauch von heute 46 auf 80% zu
steigern dazu sollen unter anderem
Meldepflichten vereinfacht werden
außerdem soll gegen Kritik des
Bauernverbandes die doppelte Nutzung
landwirtschaftliche Flächen möglich sein
weiteres Ziel eine klimaneutrale
Wärmeversorgung bis 2045 dazu hat das
Bundeskabinett einen Gesetzentwurf zur
kommunalen wärmeplanung beschlossen
Städte mit mehr als 100.000 Einwohner
haben demnach bis Mitte 2026 Zeit für
ihre Pläne zum klimafreundlichen heizen
dann soll feststehen wo Fernwärme
möglich ist wo Nahwärme etwa über
Biomasse oder wo ein wasserstoffnetz
aufgebaut werden soll
auch der langjährige Fraktionschef der
Linken Bartsch gibt sein Amt auf er
werde bei der Vorstandswahl am 4
September nicht mehr kandidieren teilte
der 65-Jährige mit die Entscheidung
falle ihm nicht leicht und habe für ihn
schon sehr sehr lange festgestanden im
Richtungsstreit um die Linken
Abgeordnete Wagenknecht hatte vor
eineinhalb Wochen bereits die
co-fraktionsvorsitzende Mohammed Ali
ihren Rückzug angekündigt
in Nigerias Hauptstadt Abuja hat
entwicklungsministerin Schulze Vertreter
der westafrikanischen
Staatengemeinschaft ECOWAS getroffen
Thema ist die angespannte Lage im
Nachbarland Niger nach dem Militärputsch
Schulze würdigte die gemeinsamen
Bemühungen der sahel-region für eine
friedliche Lösung des Konflikts und eine
Rückkehr zur Demokratie sie sagte
deutsche Unterstützung zu
trotz russischer Drohungen hat ein
deutsches Containerschiff den Hafen von
Odessa verlassen und der Schwarze Meer
durchquert erstmals seit dem Ende des
getreideabkommens mit Russland der
fragte inzwischen in rumänischen
Gewässern sicher angekommen saß seit
Kriegsbeginn in der Ukraine fest
unterdessen hat Russland in der Ukraine
erneut für den Getreide
exportstrategisch wichtige donau-häfen
angegriffen Hauptziele waren Terminals
und Getreide sie los die ukrainische
Luftabwehr fing 13 russische Drohnen ab
es ist so ziemlich der schrecklichste
Job den das Auswärtige Amt im Augenblick
zu vergeben hat deutscher Botschafter in
Moskau in einer Zeit in der es keine
gesprächsferien mehr gibt sondern nur
noch Vorwürfe und das Deutschland Bild
in Moskau schlechter nicht sein könnte
die Bundesregierung eine amerikanische
Marionette die die angeblichen Nazis in
der Ukraine mit deutschen Panzern
unterstützt Alexander Graf lambsdorf hat
das Jobangebot trotzdem angenommen heute
hat er im Moskauer Außenministerium sein
Beglaubigungsschreiben abgegeben Andreas
Kühnast über eine eigentlich unmögliche
Aufgabe
sein Beglaubigungsschreiben hat
Alexander Graf Lambsdorff noch in der
Hand als er am Mittag aus dem Büro des
russischen protokollchefs kommt seit er
eine Kopie davon übergeben hat seit ein
paar Minuten ist er der achte deutsche
Botschafter in der Russischen Föderation
und der Erste der mit offener
Feindschaft manche sagen mit Hass
empfangen wird das russische
Außenministerium betont nach dem
Gespräch den konfrontativen und
unfreundlichen Charakter der deutschen
Politik die die Zusammenarbeit zerstören
Wolle und geleitet sei von
unvernünftiger russophobie
der
Bundestagsabgeordnete Lamsdorf war
bekannt für häufige und heftige
Reaktionen der Botschafter Lamsdorf
reagiert gar nicht nur ein paar harmlose
Freundlichkeiten und nur für die
sozialen Medien Alexander Graf Lamsdorf
ist jetzt Diplomat und reagiert schon
seit Wochen die problematisch
wir haben unterschiedliche Ansichten zur
Lage in der Ukraine die könnten gar
nicht unterschiedlicher sein da werden
wir uns gegenseitig versichern was die
Position unserer jeweiligen Regierung
ist aber das Entscheidende ist wenn man
nicht da ist dann kriegt man auch nicht
mit wenn sich was ändert als Lamsdorf im
vergangenen Monat seinen Bundestagsbüro
ausräumt ist sein innerer Kampf gerade
vorbei Moskau ausgerechnet er hatte
Bedenkzeit erbeten er war durch seine
Vorgänger gewarnt sie haben als
Botschafter in einem solchen Land in
einer so angespannten Situation davon
auszugehen dass sie 724 wie man sagt
sieben Tage die Woche 24 Stunden unter
Wind sind beobachtet werden abgehört
werden das muss ihre Grundhaltung prägen
lamsdorfs Eltern hat diese Haltung
geprägt sie waren in den 80er Jahren an
der Botschaft der Bundesrepublik in
Moskau tätig Vater hagengraf Lamsdorf
leitete die Kulturabteilung und brachte
seinem Sohn bei man sollte
beispielsweise einen Streit unter
Partner zu laut führen denn der wird
natürlich mitgeholt gehört wichtiges
bespricht man besser auf einem
Waldspaziergang deutsche Fahnen mit
Hakenkreuz als Siegestrophäen auf dem
Roten Platz die sowjetische Fahne über
dem Reichstag der Nürnberger Prozess
diese phototafeln hat vermutlich
russlandsverteidigungsministerium vor
der deutschen Botschaft aufbauen lassen
einer Botschaft die einmal die größte
deutsche Auslandsvertretung war aber
nach zahlreichen gegenseitigen
diplomatenausweisungen unter enormer
Personalnot leidet das beeinträchtliche
die Möglichkeit in den Feldern rechts
und links der großen Politik Analyse zu
leisten miteinander im Gespräch zu
bleiben Lamsdorf ist kein
russlandversteher er versteht die Gegner
von Waffenlieferungen nicht er hat die
Friedensbewegung kritisiert Lamsdorf
ausgerechnet
ich zähle auf die professionellen
Kontakte dort zu den Vertretern der
russischen Regierung diplomatische
Beziehungen sind ja sozusagen das
Rückgrat von allem anderen und ich zähle
einfach darauf dass dieser
professionelle Kontakt auch weiterhin
möglich ist die russische Regierung hat
Lamsdorf nicht gerade freundlich
empfangen die deutsche Botschaft nicht
gerade feierlich
der wichtigste Posten den das Auswärtige
Amt zu besetzen hat ist vergeben
und wir machen hier weiter mit
Nachrichten zunächst aus der Wirtschaft
und mit Gundula die Bedrohung deutscher
Unternehmen und Behörden durch
kriminelle Cyberangriffe bleibt hoch das
Bundeskriminalamt registrierte im
vergangenen Jahr zehntausende Fälle und
Milliarden Schäden Frank bieten an der
Börse und das soll nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs sein ja die Ermittler gehen
davon aus dass nur jeder zehnte Fall
überhaupt bekannt wird also die
Dunkelziffer liegt weit höher als die
über
130.000 Fälle die im vergangenen Jahr
registriert wurden viele Cyberangriffe
richten sich gegen Unternehmen ihnen
entstand 2022 einen Schaden in Höhe von
über 200 Milliarden Euro aber da eben
längst nicht alle Attacken bekannt
werden dürften die tatsächlichen Schäden
noch deutlich höher sein Firmen müssen
also in IT-Sicherheit investieren wie
weit ist das in der Wirtschaft
angekommen ja die Sensibilität ist da
aber noch längst nicht Bildschirm ist
klar was das bedeutet nämlich intensive
Schulung der Mitarbeiter wo lauern die
Gefahren und vor allem müssen die
IT-Ausgaben für Sicherheitssysteme
vielerorts deutlich hochgefahren werden
wie ernst die Bedrohung in den meisten
Unternehmen inzwischen wahrgenommen wird
zeigt eine aktuelle Umfrage des
Branchenverbandes Bitkom demnach rechnen
in den kommenden zwölf Monaten 63% der
befragten Firmen damit dass sie Opfer
von Cyberangriffen werden noch
erschrecken davon diesen Unternehmen
sagen 57% sie erwarten Schwierigkeiten
bei der Abwehr dieser Angriffe der
Appell von Bundeskriminalamt und Bitkom
an die Unternehmen heute daher eindeutig
es sei höchste Zeit aufzuwachen vielen
Dank an Anfang
wieder sind schwere Gewitter quer über
Deutschland gezogen für die Abendstunden
waren der Deutsche Wetterdienst noch vor
heftigen Gewittern in Teilen von Hessen
und Baden-Württemberg viele Regionen in
Rheinland-Pfalz oder Bayern wurden
bereits von heftigen Regenfällen
Gewittern und Sturmböen getroffen
Starkregen führte zu überfluteten
Straßen weil die Kanäle die Wassermassen
nicht fassen konnten die Feuerwehren
waren viele Orts im Einsatz
die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch
lauten ohne Gewähr 4 5 14 19 26 41
Superzahl 8 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
Lotto zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
zur Fußball-WM der Frauen das Finale am
Sonntag werden Spanien und England
bestreiten zu sehen im ZDF ab 12 Uhr im
Halbfinale bezwangen die
Europameisterinnen aus England
Australien ein bitteres aus für die
co-gastgeberinnen
Australiens Fans aus allen finalträumen
gerissen zu stark zu abgeklärte
Europameisterinnen aus England den
ersten Dämpfer verpassen Sie den WM
Gastgeberinnen in der 36 Minute
Ella tune und widerstehlich nach dem
Wechsel lässt sein Körper die
australischen Fans noch mal hoffen
erstmals nach Verletzung in der Stadt 11
begeistert der Superstar der Mathildas
mit dieser Einzelleistung zum 1:1
8 Minuten lang scheint nun alles möglich
doch dann bestraft Lauren Hamp das zu
zögerliche Eingreifen von
Elli Carpenter England wieder vorn für
den Endstand zum 3:1 sorgt in der 86
Minute Alessia Russo die
Europameisterinnen nach ihrer besten
Turnierleistung im Endspiel
und das war es von uns im
auslandsjournal direkt nach uns
berichten wir über die Spurensuche nach
den Ursachen für das Inferno auf der
Hawaii-Insel Maui und die Verzweiflung
der Überlebenden und wir sagen wenn Sie
mögen bis morgen einen schönen Abend und
tschüss
[Musik]
einen wunderschönen guten Abend zum
Wetter in Deutschland ist es im Moment
schwül wie selten das bringt uns hohe
Luftfeuchte und die liefert die Energie
für diese vielen schweren Gewitter
zurzeit der Schwerpunkt lag heute
zunächst in Baden-Württemberg da hat
eine Zelle bei Villingen-Schwenningen
über 50 Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter in
nur eine Stunde gebracht dann verschob
sich der Fokus aber auch diesen Gewitter
komplett hier der aus Frankreich jetzt
über das Saarland und Rheinland-Pfalz
hinweggezogen ist wenn wir genauer
hinschauen sehen wir in der letzten
Stunde hat es vor allem im
Rhein-Main-Gebiet gekracht der
Frankfurter Flughafen Mars in nur 10
Minuten 15 Liter pro Quadratmeter also
wir sehen schon die höchste Gefahr geht
von Starkregen und Überflutungen aus
aber auch schwere Sturmböen und Hagel
können dann noch dabei sein wenn es in
den nächsten Stunden dann weiter
Richtung Mittel und Nordhessen und
Richtung östliches Nordrhein-Westfalen
geht heute Nacht kommt das ganze dann
bis morgen früh noch Richtung sachsen-an
kalt und südliche Niedersachsen voran
verfolgen Sie bitte die Warnung des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes morgen
Vormittag verschiebt sich der Komplex
dann Richtung Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
anfangs ist noch stark kriegen möglich
im Süden beginnt der Tag mit viel Sonne
nachmittags bilden sich dann aber hier
nochmal Lokal Unwetter im Nordosten
beruhigt sich allerdings die Lage die
Temperaturen sinken in der Nacht auf 19
bis 11 Grad ganz im Norden im Nordwesten
ja die weniger warme und trockenere
Luftmasse im Moment auch da erreichen
wir morgen 20 bis 23 Grad im Süden gibt
es aber eine hohe Wärmebelastung bei 27
bis 31 Grad und das steigert sich zum
Wochenende noch den Süden erwartet eine
enorme Hitzewelle bei Temperaturen bis
zu 35 Grad die Gewitter werden aber
weniger und damit auf Wiedersehen